crois-tu vraiment que tu pourrais me battre
dans une bagarre à l'ancienne,
laisse-moi te dire quelque chose moi et toi en
tête-à-tête,
personne d'autre autour de moi, je vais te battre le cul
comme un tambour Cherokee peut-être ce
qu'ils découvriront oh  tu ferais mieux d'espérer que ce
jour ne viendra jamais
n'oublie pas cette fille oh c'est juste un
dysfonctionnement dysfonctionnement allons-
y  toujours sur nous, vous le
prenez personnellement en venant, nous venons de faire sauter leur
établissement et de vendre leur EMP autre que
le doigt d'or de votre médecin, je dirais que c'est à
peu près comme l'affection personnelle leur fait
face - donc vous ne gardez pas cela pour
vous  - suis mon exemple d'accord hein
dropper bombs away
[Musique]
Holy
caps away laisse moi te demander quelque chose Don
quelle est la meilleure chose dans ta vie
famille non ce n'est
pas si tu es honnête c'est les dix
secondes entre le début et la fin quand
tu '  Je ne pense à rien,
pas de famille, pas d'obligation  igations juste pour vous, visez
librement,
je dois vous dire tout ce qui sauve le
monde Robin des Bois absurdes vient de faire
récemment, ne soyez pas qui vous êtes alors qu'il n'y a
qu'un quart de mile à la fois où vous
pouvez vivre toute votre vie de cette façon Domon
laisse la masse  somme profonde entre ces
deux pense qu'il y a des âmes sœurs,
ils représentent cet amour idéal et je
pense que cette connexion a
bien aidé tout le film, juste en quelque sorte garder un
cœur sous toute l'action dans
le jargon de la marche du chaos
Je ne veux pas de toi  quand ils
me rattrapent, je pense que ce que Letty admire
chez Dom, c'est l'indépendance, c'est
un enthousiasme libre pour la vie.
les âmes sœurs
lors de l'indexation apparaissent en fait le quatrième
chapitre, son aile Dom explique
enseigne à tous qui cette fille
allait avoir ce genre d'yeux peut
regarder droit vers le bon intestin que
vous devez avoir  l'aimais beaucoup
[Musique]
mets-toi au sol j'ai Toretto c'est comme une nouvelle
relation car tu sais DOM et Elena se
déguisent en criminel tu es en état d'arrestation
et elle ne voit pas qu'en lui
[Musique]
ils sont exactement pareils  situation
DOM et Elena parce qu'ils ont tous les deux
perdu la vie
hé ils ont l'impression qu'ils sont peut-être les seuls à
pouvoir comprendre quelle que soit
sa spécialité
je pensais que tout le monde pouvait comprendre à quel
point ce que vous faites Salmonella non pas
ensemble je vis dans les îles Canaries  nous
savons que Michelle est vivante mais maintenant c'est un
conflit pour stupide était comme ce qu'elle
allait faire
c'est la seule chose qui aurait pu
paralyser DOM et lui faire deviner
tout en laissant n'est-ce pas je pense
qu'elle est vraiment forte pour pouvoir le dire
allez et faites tout ce que vous avez à faire est
d'aller bien laissez-le elle peut très bien
être longue nous avons regardé Dom devoir s'accrocher
à la conviction qu'elle l'aimait
mon pote
cette femme vous tire dessus et il
essaie de le dire à tous ses copains  elle
m'aime et son Alethia veut que je parte tu
ne penses pas au combat même quand ils le
font ils ont été ensemble en enfer et de
retour
c'est avec le changement de combinaison ces
deux personnages sont tellement électrisants
ensemble à l'écran
comment se passe cette lune de miel tu vois
c'est  la chose amusante à propos de la
ruse du destin peut vous apporter de belles choses
et vous pouvez également vous apporter des moments comme
celui-ci voir votre équipe est sur le point d'
affronter la seule chose qu'ils ne peuvent pas gérer
ce qui vous arrive
[Musique]
Je vis ma vie à un quart de mile  à la fois
et rien d'autre n'a d'importance
pendant ces 10 secondes ou à gauche,
je suis libre la route ouverte
pourrait vous emmener n'importe où entre amis à la
famille nous savons qu'il y a un O'Conner mais
s'il vous plaît ne passez pas par la foule ou l'
aventure faisons-le
pour  voir quelque chose de nouveau que voulez-vous dire
trois juste pour revenir à la maison appelez-
moi doux Oh
les attaches ici est la saga a exploré
les possibilités infinies de la route ouverte
depuis la rue juste à l'extérieur du centre-ville de
Los Angeles nous vous avons emmené à Miam  je
vous ai emmené à Tokyo
République dominicaine Rio Londres Abu Dhabi et maintenant
notre nom est connu dans le monde entier nous
avons couru pour la vitesse couru pour l'honneur de
Thomas avait des greens ou des villes dévalant des
montagnes et même tombé du
ciel mais non  peu importe la façon dont nos aventures se
développent
Fast and the Furious est toujours à propos d'une
chose très importante la
chose la plus importante dans la vie sera
toujours les gens dans cette pièce me trompent
familier
notre famille de personnages font tout les
uns pour les autres et les uns avec les autres pour
les millions qui  formons notre
famille mondiale de fans, nous nous poussons à aller
plus loin et à faire mieux à chaque fois
[Musique]
nous ne roulons jamais nous ne roulons jamais seuls
nous ne roulons jamais seuls cette fois, il ne s'agit pas
seulement d'être une mode maintenant nous nous lançons dans
notre  prochain chapitre, notre famille sera
défiée comme jamais auparavant par des
adversaires qui ne montrent aucune pitié pour tester les
bombes qui nous ont toujours maintenus
ensemble le
plus ambitieux le plus divertissant
Dartmouth et le plus furieux Raya
[Musique]
a  et c'est doux et sûr que
vous
Sanofi le franchiseur est différent de tout ce
que j'ai jamais vu
vous avez des fans dans le monde entier la façon
dont nous avons la motivation et l'
inspiration dépasse votre
imagination la plus folle et des fans incroyablement
fidèles mais ils sont aussi très  très vocal,
vous savez que vous écoutez le public, nous
ressentons le poids de cela et à cause de
cela, nous avançons, ce que nous voulions
faire était de capitaliser sur ce que le côté
est représenté au cours des deux dernières décennies
et d'essayer de le défier, un sacré
travail  frère quand nous revenons au visage des
bières sur moi, la seule façon dont nous allons vraiment
pouvoir continuer cette histoire était d'
exposer le côté le plus sombre et le plus dangereux du
dr.  Adam et naturellement
il est trop tard pour moi de sortir d'ici
Tamir Toretto vient de nous allumer c'est
une histoire complètement différente de celle que vous avez
jamais vécue dans la franchise précédente
Dom c'est toujours une question de famille et avec
ce scénario, il affronte l'
équipe et il est  affronter la
famille quelle meilleure façon de brûler
toute cette franchise sur sa tête et de faire
quelque chose comme ça
avez-vous déjà pensé que vous trahiriez votre
famille comme vous l'avez fait aujourd'hui laissez-moi
ajouter l'élément du tort de Charlie
J'adore ça Charlize  est dans ce film,
elle a vraiment donné le ton, elle est certainement
la méchante la plus féroce que la franchise ait
jamais vue, c'est un tout nouveau départ à
travers la franchise et c'est ce que nous
continuons à faire, c'est de nous réinventer,
sortez, cliquez sur la molette, quel
méchant fou d'
accord, vous obtenez du style  des points pour celui-
là Oh Davis apparaît va souffler
l'esprit des gens souffler le feu de l'esprit des gens
ouais
[Musique]
tu es
Dominic Toretto juste devenu un voyou
tu vas tourner le dos  famille
[Musique]
Je t'emmène donc écris où je
suis si tu vas attraper doc tu
vas avoir besoin d'un peu d'aide tu veux
me dire pourquoi tu viens de me mettre dans une pièce
avec un criminel tu n'as pas '  Je ne pense pas que les
plantations sont un peu l'enfer de la circulation
Brian, tu devrais me faire soupirer,
vous allez travailler ensemble
[Musique
] Non Papa va abandonner aujourd'hui
]
premier jour avec la voiture déplaçant tout le monde
[Musique]
vous
nous sommes à Cuba le premier
film hollywoodien mondial à permettre à des spéciaux
de venir ici et vous pouvez ressentir l'
émotion de chacun d'eux oh nous
ne pouvions pas le recréer de toute façon d'
accord je  besoin d'en regarder pour que ça sonne
réel et pour le plafond petite flèche
heureux tout le monde est excité
maintenant nous devons ramasser le gâchis
au nom de notre production, je voudrais
demander au chef de la cit  y de la question
que nous perdons, allons-y, avez-vous l'
impression que nous honorons
la saga Fast and Furious avec le chapitre huit
parce que vous tous qui travaillez dur
et je pense qu'il peut y avoir ouais ouais ouais
ouais eh bien nous allons  Gros bébé, tu penses
que les fans vont être vraiment excités
par ce qu'ils vont faire, tu as l'
impression qu'un film riche va avoir le
niveau d'action que notre meilleure position et
faire pousser la crème
[Musique]
Aimes-tu ce que tu es  disant bon
hippocampe alors nous voici dans le magasin de jouets
c'est l'un des ensembles les plus incroyables
que j'aie jamais vus
ce que j'aime à propos de cet endroit c'est un
grand contraste avec Cuba c'est beaucoup de
voitures technologiquement avancées quand vous
avez une nouvelle petite ligue  la McLaren est la
Maseratis et la mercedes-benz les jaguars
et bien sûr l'un des véhicules d'assaut les plus avancés sur le plan
technologique
sur la planète Terre et à un endroit,
cela vous donne l'impression d'être dans un autre
temps, la seule chose qui
vous ramène en quelque sorte qui est un  de mon préféré
voitures est la Corvette est qu'un bateau de course
vous vous sentez comme dans le futur ici
au magasin de jouets et j'adore ça
Je les ai laissés utiliser mon garage aujourd'hui pour
filmer cette image
vous
qui déclarez que nous sommes ici à mi-chemin
et  ça se passe phénoménalement je
dois dire que ça va au delà de mes
espérances sinon le patient a
refusé
vraiment remarquable de voir tout le monde désirer
les faire dans tous les nourris au
Bristol regarde les boites qui descendent
on va pas lâcher car on
sait  quand vous avez quelque chose de spécial, vous
lui donnez tout de votre âme, je ne peux pas
croire que vous le voyez, nous sommes à mi-
chemin et nous sourions pour Reece et
je pense qu'ils nous appellent la Parole de Dieu,
ils vous remercient pour toujours
nous soutenir pour faire des affaires
vous
Valona
Ouganda pris personnellement vous n'étiez
censé créer qu'une diversion romaine
qui achèverait la destruction de ce que vous
voulez pour moi Je suis un homme de larmes romaines c'est ce que
je
fais  sais ce que j'aime  e à propos de toi aube
tu es un véritable hors-la-loi va te faire [ __ ] sa
famille un sacré boulot frère
quand nous reviendrons à la base bières sur moi
le meilleur affronte tout ce qu'ils
ne peuvent pas gérer tu
as-tu déjà pensé que tu trahirais  ta
famille comme tu l'as fait aujourd'hui Dominic
Toretto vient de nous attaquer eh
bien regarde regarde ça
je ne sais pas pourquoi il fait ça mais
ce n'était pas idiot elle est la
définition même du terrorisme de haute technologie maintenant
elle travaille avec ton mec  Je pense que j'ai
trouvé comme ça devrait être
intéressant
[Music]
veux jouer comme ça
[Applaudissements
] c'est
impossible c'est pourquoi ils vont avoir besoin d'un peu d'
aide Je vais te battre comme un
tambour Cherokee nous sommes sur le point d'y aller oh ça a pris
plus de temps  que ce à quoi je m'attendais
si vous avez fait une prise, vous
allez travailler ensemble surprise je tombe juste
amoureux j'attendais ça nous
avons un tank revenons dans la coupe
comme si je ne savais pas que l'ancien Dom est
là-dedans
Je m'en fous, je t'abats
donc bon ok joue où tu ne penses pas que je
e
Je ne sais pas peut-être viens tu es toujours
Lamborghini c'est ce que tu n'aimes pas
les explosions de bus cornichons allez
nous sommes la bouteille s'en va comme ça
Oh tu vois nous allons avoir besoin d'un plus gros
camion
[Musique]
tu vas  tournez le dos à la famille
vous
[Musique]